fires burning in the streets of the
haitian capital
while protests over worsening insecurity
have swept the city in recent days
demonstrations over fuel shortages are
also becoming a daily occurrence
there are fears the city would come to a
standstill if supplies aren't resumed
soon
the government is not doing its job they
are the ones that should give us
security they should do everything to
make sure pumps have petrol so we can do
what we have to do
despite some gas stations already
running dry cues of motorists keep
growing as do tensions at the pump
the problem is the people in government
the rich are fighting the poor
some motorists tell us fuel is becoming
so hard to come by it can take days to
get their hands on only a few gallons
across the haitian capital many petrol
stations have closed their doors
altogether creating a black market for
fuel in recent days the price of
gasoline has gone from ten dollars to
fifteen dollars per gallon and it's a
cost that's only getting higher as the
fuel shortage worsens
delivering fuel to residents has become
more difficult as violence linked to
criminal gangs spreads to more parts of
the city gang members have made a
lucrative business out of extorting and
kidnapping petrol delivery drivers
fuel transporters are threatening a
strike to protest against the violence
directed towards delivery personnel
a reason why there's no petrol is that
some of the drivers have been kidnapped
previously with their trucks the owners
have paid for the truck to be released
but left the driver behind and they were
killed that's why drivers are now scared
to go to the cargo terminal because they
may get kidnapped
though the recent abduction of 17
missionaries by a haitian gang has
captured global headlines violence and
kidnappings are a challenge that most
residents here face on a daily basis and
between increasing insecurity fast
rising fuel prices and an economic
crisis exacerbated by the ongoing kobit
19 pandemic security experts say the
situation is a ticking time bomb for
social unrest
manuel rapalo al jazeera port-au-prince